hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
i hme covet 19 projections for the u.s
strategies to reduce the spread this
webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credit
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located on the top right hand corner of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker
dr ali moghdad chief strategy officer
with population health at the university
of washington
for a complete biography of our speakers
please visit by the biography tab at the
top of your
screen dr mogdad welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
thank you for the introduction good
morning everybody it's a pleasure to be
with you this morning
i want to talk about the ihme cover 19
models
and strategies to reduce the spread of
government 19.
my presentation will introduce the model
drivers of the model
projections for the united states i'll
talk about our limitations
and how can states use these estimates
to control the pandemic
before i do so let me tell you briefly
about the institute for health metric
and evaluation
uh we are based at the university of
washington we've been here about 11
years
and we monitor address three questions
uh
what is the world's major health
problems
what is the society doing to address
these problems and the third one which
is the most important is how can we
giving the resources that we have at
hands how can we maximize our
output for covert 19 we have a large
team working on government 19
projections
led by our director christopher murray
and several faculty here
as well as post-bachelor fellows data
analysts and of course
engineers and enterprise data managers
and visualization as you will see
all our data is available with a
visualization on our web page
the history of our model it's originally
started by a
request from uw medicine here our
hospitals we have one large
hospital here which is a referral
hospital for
the whole region and reality and
they came to us and asked if we can
provide projections
about how many beds they will need how
many ice to use how many ventilators so
they can prepare for the search
started doing this for our hospital and
our county an adjacent
county where our catchment area for the
hospitals
are and then we got requests and we
started releasing this for every state
in the united states and now we do it
for every country in the world
and for many countries we do it at the
sub national as well
what we are trying to answer is how many
people are dying
will die from covert 19 will project
four months into the future
and we decided that ihme to do
projections based on deaths
as you will see in my talk because early
on we didn't have enough testing
and we didn't know how many people in a
community are
infected so we felt mortality is a
better
indicator of what's happening if we
follow mortality and we do projections
of mortality we can
back calculate what is needed for
example
how many people are dying and then we
can look at how many people were
admitted so that ratio for each desk how
many admissions we have
who's in this admission what's the lands
of stay
how many people are on an icu how many
people are on a ventilator of course by
age by sex for
all of those and we provide scenarios
right now
for our estimates so what if 95
of the population were in mass which is
what we see in singapore and other
countries
in asia and what if we keep release
relaxing our social distancing mandate
what will happen
and if do we follow the reference
scenario that
i will explain shortly
and as i mentioned we take the ace
specific
deaths using age pattern of mortality
reported to us
we now give you the sources of the data
medium time of admission to dust
and then we back calculate how many
people were on a
icu how many invasive ventilators using
the lens of stay
as well to know how much not only
beds you need but bad days as well
our data sources are
from johns hopkins we use johns hopkins
they have a wonderful web and a lot of
good great data that we can easily
download
we've got covered the tracking
projections where they have
our word and data where they have a lot
of testing data as well
uh social distancing data is obtained by
a number of different sources but
basically we look at countries and state
when did they
impose a mandate what type of mandate
mobility we get it from facebook data
for good
google safe graph and the car
and internationally we get it from
facebook and google
mass views in the united states we get
it from premise
everywhere else in the world it's from
facebook they do about five
million surveys a week and they add
questions we work with them both premise
and facebook and we get that data from
them to use it in our modeling
hospitalization rates we have
several locations like in my state for
example we don't know how many people
were admitted in the hospital we know in
our hospitals
but not in the state hospitals but that
data when available
we use it in our models
some of the data we get is problematic
this is an example from the uk and you
will see later on in the united states
is
unfortunately the same the several
problems are there one of it is
unfortunately on saturday and sunday and
monday
you see less reporting and you can see
it clearly here there's a gap
and then you see a number increasing
then it comes down
then it goes really down on the weekend
on monday
it is reported on tuesday and that's not
a fault for any health department
you know on the weekend that you're
collecting the data compiling it and
releasing it
on whenever it's available it's a monday
or tuesday so you see the zigzag
and data comes in one day more than
other day
and we have here a way to go and
reassign those desks to a previous day
based on what the trend that we have
seen in the past week
it's very important for us to do so
otherwise
our models will if we do it let's say if
we run it
on monday it's uh assuming that the
cases are the death
is coming down and cases are coming down
and so on so would impact our
projections
all what i'm presenting to you is
available on our web if you google ihme
cover 19
you'll have the model and for every
country in the world you will have
all the variables that we use and our
models you have notes for
uh updates on our changes and
methodology
and all our publications you could
download the estimates yourself
you could download some of the
visualizations uh there is a way to do
so
under we answer some frequently asked
questions
let me briefly talk to you about the
model that we are doing
we are in our third version of the model
and that's
very important finding that we have
realized in our work and for government
our first model
first release was march 26 for the
united states
from march 26 to may 3rd we were using a
curve fit model
and that model did ex extremely well
predicting the peak of the pandemic
in the united states but after that the
decline
it didn't do at all very good and the
reason for it
early on we didn't have data about what
will happen
once you reach a peak all the data we
had before
was coming from china south korea italy
and spain they were ahead of us
when it came to the pandemic spread
in these countries the model was
symmetric so it would curve
it went up and it came down in the
united states it came down
slowly and dragged for a long time
that assumption didn't fit so we
switched to a uh
curve fit scr model and i'll show you
what we mean
by sar susceptible exposed infected and
recovered
and that hybrid model did very well
until june 10
then when we came down and then we
started going up
we switched to what we call random knot
combinations flying
the best way to describe it is like when
we were kids
we used to draw a picture by connecting
one two
two three four and five that models
takes the short distance between two
points
and curve it and make it occur
and in our random not combinations
flying and
se ir hybrid model right now
we use for our projections mask
use cell phone mobility data
pneumonia seasonality because we find it
very strongly associated with covert 19
testing per capita early on testing was
very significant because the more you
test the more you find cases and you're
likely to remove them
from exposing others by isolating them
population density you know big cities
they live together
you know public transportation and
elevators and so on
particulate matter 2.5 smoking is a big
variable
altitude and pneumonia because of the
pneumonia
and the way we do it is we take the past
eight days in
all our models and we look at the
relationship between these variables and
and our outcome that's in this case in
the past eight days
and we built that relationship
and then we project all the variables
into the future
all the indicators and then we can
project mortality into the future and we
do it the last eight days because things
are changing
and the relationship once things are
changing the relationship between these
variables do change
and we take the last eight days eight
days to adjust for this
issue of uh declining reporting over the
weekend to make sure we cover
a period of reporting for the whole week
and for those of you who do modeling and
projections for infectious diseases it's
susceptible to many
people and what the percentage of the
population that's susceptible
how many of them are exposed and we have
two
eye infected and infectious so some
people are
infected but they're not infectious and
they are infectious for a certain period
of time and they become
and they turn out not to be and removed
as ease of recovery or
unfortunately does and that's what we
are predicting we are predicting a
better
that people in our business talk about
are not
we are interested in rt
which is effective r because r is
changing
throughout the time are not is at the
beginning of a
epidemic or pandemic from infectious
disease modern
the problem with s-e-i-r models
they tend to overestimate a
the number if you don't account for what
the population is to it so if you take a
model for example
susceptible and exposed and infected
and you don't take into account what the
country is doing or what people are
doing to change their behavior
that model will assume the same will
stay constant
and will project an over estimate of the
number of deaths so that's what happened
with the imperial model
and our modeling early on we decided
that no
we it's not gonna no country or no
location in the world will allow a
pandemic
to keep rolling without taking some
measures and
the measures early on were mandates in
our model so we looked at what china did
and when china started imposing mandates
closure of educational
shutting down the airport and like six
mandates that every country used
we've seen the impact of these mandates
and we put a prior in our model so we
told our model basically
one a state would put such a mandate we
expect
a certain percentage decline in
infection
and that's what happened and we use that
so countries do provide the response and
it's
kind of accounted in our model with all
or
what i'm saying right now is all of our
attempts to make sure that we
don't overestimate the numbers for many
locations
unfortunately especially for sub-saharan
africa our model and many of other
models
don't perform as well as they perform
in europe for example or the united
states for several reasons
that i will briefly discuss in our
limitation
but to give you an idea what
what we do here in our data and how we
use it for projection
if you look at the top left cumulative
desks we're running cumulative desks by
daily desks
so if you look at daily desks at the
bottom this is what we get on a daily
from
for florida and you could see there's
exactly more time it goes up comes down
on the daily basis
and you could also tell when the
weekends happen
so we're plotting because we know
cumulative dust is not as sensitive
up and down zigzag like a daily does
we plot uh daily decisions by
commutativeness and we can get
understand the relationship between
daily deaths and communities
we do the same for right now for cases
so the the one in the middle commutative
deaths versus cases
so on the axis we have cases daily cases
at the bottom graph you see daily cases
they go up and down zigzag and they've
been increasing in florida at that time
now they're coming down if you look at
the end of the
graph here again we plot daily basis by
cumulative deaths
admissions to the hospital in florida we
have admissions
you could see the bottom hospital
admission it's going up and down as
exactly reporting
and whereas it's a better relationship
when you look at hospital admissions
with
uh cumulative deaths and then if you
come back to the daily desk graph the
red line
takes all this information so daily
cases cumulative deaths
admissions to the hospitals and plot
that curve the red one that goes
into it and ex shows the trend so it
went up early april and florida came
down
and now it came up and now it started to
come down
but that's how we do it and using the
past eight days we get the relationship
between the covariate let me show you
that
so in social uh distancing measures
mandates there are six of them
educational facility closed
non-essential business people ordered to
stay at home severe travel restriction
partial non-essential business order to
crew some state did that in the united
states
and restricted the group gathering
different size but
there was a group gathering destruction
but there's six mandate that every
country used and we use these six
mandates in our estimate
so let me show you what happened in the
in globally
all countries in the world all countries
all state
impose certain mandate not sex you know
i'm plotting here six the highest is sex
mandates
but you could see all countries in the
world
by mid-march started imposing mandates
so all the mandates came at the same
time and that has given many
countries a false sense of security and
i will explain it for the case of
florida for
example when you will see later in one
of my examples so
what happened here is when a state put a
mandate say new york state
and the time that new york state put a
mandate there was a lot of infection
going on because new york and
washington state my state were ahead of
everybody
in terms of the case exceeding of the
number of cases
for example a state like florida when
they imposed a mandate
they didn't have as many cases at that
time
so for a long time they felt
safe in a way and they can lift this
mandates because the mandate showed like
basically there is not that much effect
when they were lifted
uh because of the seeding in florida
there were not much
cases early on for him once or so after
lifting the mandate
they didn't have cases then they started
going up because this is an infectious
disease we're all susceptible it's
highly infectious
it will go to exponential growth once
given so
that issue of early mandate for certain
places
unfortunately led to a full sense of
security in the future and sometimes
states that relax and didn't pay
attention people didn't see copper 19 in
their community
and they felt safe and they're immune to
it then
unfortunately 19 came and hit them
to show another point these are two
graphs one in south africa were in an
india location you could see it
mandates came down about the same time
mobility went down extremely
in our web page we have the timing of
the mandate
a nice visualization hard to see what's
available on our web
but you could see for every state when
did they impose the mandate and how many
mandates they have
none uh only one state has six mandates
top to travel
but all other state at one point of time
have five mandates maximum and
the duration varied by state of course
so mobility as measured uh by mobile
phone and i have to be very careful as
an epidemiologist in the united states
most people have a mobile phone and
a smartphone but in many international
countries that's not true so we tend to
overestimate a decline in mobility
because the rich and affluent people are
answering in other countries say where i
come from in lebanon
but in the united states that's not a
huge problem
but if you look at the map in the united
states right now
many states are almost back to normal
mobility
similar mobility that was in january
unfortunately we don't have mobility
before
january from our sources so our baseline
is january we wish of course to have a
baseline to be the same months august
compared to previous occurs because we
know
some people do travel more what's
important in this graph is you could see
that states that are
impacted impacted the most tend to have
less mobility and we see that
response so we see when they stay in new
york city
as a problem people are more likely to
wear a mask
people are more likely to stay at home
then when the cases start coming down
they relax and they let down their
drought and they start
excuse me moving around much faster so
if you look at mobility here in the
united states i'm giving you some states
uh you could see it came down sharply
after the mandate if you look at florida
here the
light blue line florida that put one
mandate
compared to new york and my state
washington it was one mandate florida
mobility went down to like minus 56
by closing educational facility because
in many places educational facilities
especially schools are associated with
other activities besides kids coming to
school
there are parents meeting there are
sports activities so you see it coming
down the other important point here
you could see mobility in florida and
other states started coming up even
before lifting the mandates
so uh in florida for example i'm not
picking on florida but it's a
i have the data for it and we have
hospitalization from florida
for florida for example you could see
the first week of april mobility started
going
up even before lifting the mandate
and the reason here is when you start
talking about lifting the mandate and
everything is going in the right
direction people
start moving around they in their mind
you know it's getting better
now the governor or the state health
officials are talking about
opening the country or the state it
means we're in good shape
so mobility started going up even before
a mandate was lifted so for us early on
when we didn't have mobility data and we
were counting on a mandate
we assumed that mobility was very low
because we have a mandate still in place
when we got the mobility data our
estimate of course went up because we
realized mobility started before the
mandates were lifted
we're learning a lot from the data and
what's happening here
as this pandemic is unfolding
unfortunately in the united states
these are the percentage of people
prevalence of people who
when they are outside their houses they
report wearing a
mask and you can see in many places in
the states about 50
right now it went down the last week
unfortunately
and you could see that many states are
less than 30 percent people wearing
masks again you could see
more mask wearing in florida texas and
california
because of the recent increase
and people react when they hear in the
news their state is not doing well
they wear a mask they stay at home then
when the
numbers come down unfortunately they the
reverse is true
here is some state you could see mass
warning was coming up for all states
even national
it's coming down the past two weeks
unfortunately it's coming down we're
getting into fall and winter where
seasonality will increase over 19 and we
need to be much careful right now rather
than relaxing
this is daily testing of covert 19 and
in the united states by state so some
state do more testing new york for
example stands out that doing more
testing
followed of course by several states
that have been heavily impacted by
covert 19.
early on in our model testing was
strongly associated with
a reduction in transmission it's not as
much anymore right now we see
almost no effect of testing which is
very controversial
but because there are delays in the
results that's one
two because right now the number of
cases that we are catching on a regular
basis
are very hard to do contact tracing and
isolation and testing of the contacts so
for example if you take florida
one point at a time they have 15 000
cases a day it's
very hard for a health department to
praise fifteen thousand
and still they had another ten thousand
or twelve thousand the day before and so
on
this is trend in uh daily uh testing
per one hundred thousand compared the us
to other countries it's very important
to
remind ourselves that we're doing a good
job in testing it slowed down
at the past couple of months that's now
speaking up but we have
really increased our capacity for
testing in the united states and we are
doing a lot of tests so that has
improved this is percent of people who
are
we estimate from our models that have
been infected
so it's very important people talk about
this herd immunity that
we're going to get a hurt immunity if a
lot of us are infected
we are still far away from a herd
immunity
the highest we see right now is in new
jersey new york and louisiana because of
the
infections that happen in these states
but most state in the united states are
still less than 10
in terms of infection so lots of us
are still susceptible for this virus and
we have to be very careful
trends of percent uh who are infected
you could see it as increasing
uh california now is when out florida is
going up this is our ability to
detect how many people are the change in
infection ray
uh and that we are able to detect so
basically out of
every infection that's out there how
many we are
able to detect in the united states it's
improving it's increasing not everywhere
new york has been flat because even with
their increase of their testing
large population but in other places out
of every
[Music]
100 cases that have over 19
for example about 37
have been detected in california for
example so we have a lot of cases out
there
because they're asymptomatic that we are
not able to do that so many people are
infectious and walking around that's why
it's very important for all of us to
assume we are infected
with our mass this is a graph of showing
you the pneumonia and ammonia deaths
by week in the united states for the
past
five years and this is the last year
you could see it goes up it doesn't come
down to zero it's
not like flu flow almost you don't see
any flu past may very rarely
but pneumonia sticks around but it goes
up again
and fall and winter in the united states
we see a
strong association between covenanting
mortality and pneumonia and us we've
seen it in the
northern hemisphere if you take data
from australia south africa argentina
that's the beauty of ihme because we do
this at the global level we have data
from everywhere
for example argentina whose older strict
mandates cases kept going up into the
winter
now it's coming down and it could not be
explained by mass
wearing and by mobility so it was
a strong association with pneumonia as
well
so if you look in the united states
we're coming into
the difference between august and
february is
we will see right now a rapid increase
in the chance of getting pneumonia which
means the rapid increase and the
spread of cover 19 unfortunately when we
come into fall and winter and that's why
we are concerned that our numbers
projection will increase
uh we do a good job predicting those uh
positive surveys out there so we compare
ourselves to data except for spain here
most of the surveys that this is how
what percentage of my population has
been infected and our models were very
close to that
this is available on our web but it's
very important for me that we monitor
our programs there is even a publication
by
outsiders who compare our models to our
other people who do the same all this
data is available
we do very well in our models we are the
best model out there in terms of
predicting into the future that data is
available on our web and the reference
of the publication that said that and we
do monitor ourselves as well
so in our currency ran your right now we
have uh
let's leave everything let's call it the
for the sake of this presentation heard
immunity so we ease the mandate we do
nothing and then universal mass use
which is scale up
mass used to 95 percent what will happen
and the current projection which is very
important uh
to remind everybody in our modeling is
we assume in our current projections
right now based on mobility and mass
wearing that if cases reach eight deaths
per day per million
that is already imposing for mandates
for six weeks so
in a state where we see this is going to
happen and we assume the mandate
happened
we're gonna take effect so we're gonna
underestimate mortality if the state
doesn't put that mandate in place that
happened before because we assumed that
states
will put mandates within seven days of
each release states didn't do it
we also assumed at one point of time in
our estimate
that states will not open until they
reach a certain level of infections and
we provided a map
when you can move to an open and
relaxing your mandates and many state
didn't do that so we underestimated that
but so in the united states briefly all
this data is available on our web
uh and this is the estimate from last
week we usually update our estimates on
a weekly basis so this data is
last week that's what available on our
web
we are projecting between now and
january 1st 14
of 415 000
if people wear a mass this goes down to
200
almost 230 000 a lot of lives could be
saved by 95 percent of us wearing a mask
if we go into a herd immunity we're
talking about 600 thousand deaths which
is
a huge number and we're about 200 000
deaths right now so in our
current scenario with doubling mortality
between now and january 1st
if our estimates hold it true and that's
true on a weekly basis right now proven
19
is the second leading cause of death in
the u.s but if
uh estimates hold it through by the end
of the year we will have
out 415 thousand deaths that will be the
second after ischemic heart disease in
the u.s
before lung cancer so it's a very deadly
disease
in terms of daily infections we're
expecting that december will be a bad
month we'll reach about 3 000 infections
and then close down to 2800 towards the
end of the month because of the imposing
of the mandate
this is a level that we have seen in
april
uh mid april but it will be a little bit
higher in december
if we do not do our part wearing a mask
thing away from each other and the
mandate when we reach
this is daily infections and estimate
how many infections we
have on a daily basis right now we reach
at one point of time about 350
we will see it the same way in november
december november is when we see the
highest case december when we see the
highest mortality it goes about 400
almost 450 000 on a daily basis
unfortunately if
that's our reference scenario with all
the mandates
and what we're assuming here is states
will impose these mandates they will
reach the eight
deaths per day per million and september
october november and december and very
few states will not reach that point and
will not have to impose mandates
unfortunately
it's very hard for me to talk about
mandates i have family members who
are struggling i can work from home many
of my friends and relatives cannot work
from home so it's very hard to say it
but that's a reality unfortunately
because we are afraid that
if it reaches a high level of infections
we will
overwhelm your hospitals and you need to
protect your hospital and save some bad
capacity for
other use not overnight without the
limitation briefly
i'd like to end shortly and then open it
for question
we have under testing and under
reporting in many countries uh
it does not capture our estimates the
extension of that capacity the search
hostels could add bad good at icu are
buying ventilators so we
may underestimate what a state has
unless the state calls us and provide us
this data and
it happens in the u.s we get a lot of
the update from the state
we don't know the testing who has been
tested so in many countries in the world
in the us we don't know what the
percentage of people who are symptomatic
or asymptomatic that are being tested
and for us knowing how many of the
asymptomatic are being tested and code
is very important because it tells us a
little about the infection in the
community
many hospitals many states do not tell
us how many hospitalization they have
and we don't have many zero positive
surveys
to know how many people have been
infected in a state
so we can use that information in our
projection knowing
for example in my state that 15
of the people have been infected with
hover 19 would be very helpful for us in
order to do these projections
there are a couple of things that i want
to mention that we see globally
and that's very hard for us to explain
and we follow them
in close details so i'm on the phone
talking to the minister of health and
pakistan and colleagues in pakistan if
you take pakistan for example
it peaked very poor country and places
a very dense population if you take
karachi for example or lahore
it peaked and it came down we can't
explain what happened
uh i mean they're not testing as much
people are not wearing masks as much
people are moving around so we are
speculating here that uh there are a
couple of things going on and that could
be true in many communities
in other parts of the world the first
one is there has been
previous infection of coronavirus and t
cells remember the corona virus and
they're ready
to deal with 19 so you don't see cases
cases do not
they're asymptomatic they don't come to
you because of previous exposure to
cover 19 that's one the second one
we feel that the circle the bubble of
people are interact with
at one point of time that he knows in
this bubble
the merchant the store owner who people
interact with
is either infected and removed this or
now
he or she are immune and you reach a
saturation of infection at a lower rate
of infection
what people are calling herd immunity at
a lower levels in that bubble
because you took out the key spreaders
in this community
something we are monitoring that is
under reporting of course of cases
and that's in pakistan but we know from
hospitals we know from our colleagues we
have a large network of collaborators
and
pakistan that the numbers although they
are underestimated but then
reflecting the reality so that decline
is true
the peak may have been higher and the
decline is now coming from a higher
point
but that decline is very true in many
parts of the world something to keep an
eye on with monolingual
what we expect also in addition to
monitoring mortality that there is a
strong impact of government on other key
factors domestic violence women also
productive health contraceptive
childhood immunization
people are afraid to go to doctors and
hospitals so many
chronic condition diabetes cancer there
is a delay of seeking care that will
impact health on the long run
in many countries in the world
malnutrition because people are not
making money
and their income is made on that day so
this malnutrition long-term impact of
health as well
so something to keep an eye on and we
are concerned about that at ihme
and we will see the long-term effect of
government 19 and the lockdown as well
education of course and employment which
is a
vicious cycle social determinant of
health will go down
and of course large impact on gender
equality
equality
and and what type and other types of
inequalities unfortunately so women will
suffer the most we're afraid for example
in in international countries that many
girls who didn't go to schools this year
because of cover 19 will never go back
to school unfortunately
among wr reported for example here in
the united states that there was a
decline in immunization
parents are afraid to take their kids
for to see a
physician for immunization even in the
united states so that's
very you know concerning of course there
is excess mortality in every country in
the world we see it so
here are two examples that i'm giving
you one
is if you look at what's happening in
spain for example and ecuador spain has
a better vital registration system so
there is excess mortality in the united
states we know there is excess mortality
in europe
said two hundred thousand deaths a while
back before we were
much lower than two hundred thousand
france published on access mortality
and countries like ecuador were poor
vital registration
available right now we see even much
more deaths being reported
that we can't explain what's happening
in this country except over 19 nothing
has changed
there is no war going on there is no
civil unrest no disaster natural
disaster
we have noticed in our data that states
that have mass mandate that more people
are more likely to wear a mask
and if there is that mask mandate and
even in many countries that's even
more likely to wear a mask if you look
at the globally
we in the united states do not like to
compare ourselves to other countries but
in many countries in the world there's a
penalty and level on where i come from
there's a penalty from very much you get
ticketed and this renders it
and the penalty has just recently
increased for example
we don't have a nasty random sample of
zero prevalence survey
we don't have what hospitals are doing
who's been admitted
we want to make sure we can improve the
search capacity of hospitals
we are hoping that if
cases start rising in november and
they will according to our models that
states countries will have the right
make the right decisions by closing some
of the places that
are likely to increase infections such
as bar and road dining and gasoline as
well
and then we would like to if we can
do other modeling for people like what
can we can work with some states and
show them like if you close certain
things what will happen so instead of
coming into a total shutdown you can do
partial shutdown and one of the things
that we have been asked to do is what we
call
pulse this can be modeled when we come
into winter if we shut down for two
weeks and open for four weeks so
businesses it's easier for them to know
ahead of time
when they're gonna shut down and be
ready for it so states can use this
information right now for
preparing for capacity they know when
they're going to reach a high level of
infections because we
project in fashion not detected but what
we think are the infections in that
state
and state could use this data for better
planning businesses could use this data
for better planning
this is all what i have to say thank you
very much
and i'm happy to take questions
thank you so much dr mukdad for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just by clicking that ask a question box
located on the far left
of your screen so let's get started
dr mukban there are quite a few
questions already coming in
from our audience our first one comes
from
south africa
the audience member says i wondered if
the recent theory that coronavirus
mobility is higher in ethnic minorities
has factored in the surprisingly low
death rates
in places like for example southern
africa
where the black population is the
majority instead of the minority
do you have any theories about what may
be influencing unexpectedly
low death rates in southern africa
a very good question so in many
countries in africa for example when you
see less mortality
it's you have to look at it from a
population standpoint
that's a younger population so if you
take egypt for example
uh 40 percent or even a little bit more
than 40 percent and less than 40
40 years old the population is very
young
and we know mortality is much lower and
younger age group
so that's why you see less deaths in
certain parts of africa
thank you so much regarding the cove 19
when you say it is the second leading
cause of death
in u.s how are these numbers calculated
that's the first part of the question
and does this include individuals who
die of any cause
who are covid 19 positive um
individuals in which covid19 contributed
to death from
other cormobilities or death
strictly second to the virus maybe
please
um delineate a very good question
you know cdc national center for health
statistics
has a protocol for mortality so for each
death
there is a uh underlying there is a
cause of death primary cause of death
and underlying causes of death
right now this mortality the two 196
or 97 deaths that you see in the united
states the primary cause of this is open
minded
on the death certificate somebody may
have also like they have heart attack or
they have diabetes but they died
because that carbon 19 had debated it
so we followed the previous this exactly
what used to happen with flu for example
and previous year when somebody dies
with flu and then they had a heart
problem as well nothing has changed here
so these are
the primary causes of deaths according
to icd-10 codes
according to all the protocols that cdc
has
a question that you didn't ask but
that's the most important one is
are we underestimating covert 19
mortality because
as you mentioned it's a great question
somebody could have died from a heart
attack
but because he or she had recovered 19
or afraid of over 19 didn't go for in
medical care
and how much of this death has to be
redistributed in a cyclic over 19.
this is something has to be done later
looked at our mortality in
september in the united states by state
by age by holes of deaths
and compare it to 2019 and any change
except like for fire or accidents or any
natural disaster
that could be part of it could be
attributable to covet 19. but right now
it's simply primary cause of death
underlying cause of death similar to
what we do before
good question thank you so much
and i want to thank our audience for
these great questions coming in
we love a great live audience
have you modeled how a vaccine will
affect
these numbers based on vaccine efficacy
as well like 70 percent versus 90
and also when such a vaccine is approved
for example october versus december
again a very good question yes we have
been asked to do so
and right now internally we have
extended our projections
of government mortality all the way to
january
2022 so one year from now
one year and more from now and yes we
have now doing some microsimulation when
a vaccine will be introduced
remember most of the vaccine are two
doses right now
one two those are given what will happen
we're taking different scenarios of the
efficacy of the vaccine
ihme my group we have done this work
before for other vaccines we've done
such work for the introduction of
rotavirus vaccine and others so yes
we've been asked to do it yes we are
starting to do that
very good question thank you so much
dr mark dad would you mind putting up
the slide
that had the six mandates um back up on
the screen
we've got a couple of questions focusing
on that slide
and had that request and one of the
questions
that our audience member asked was
which of these mandates do you believe
is the most pertinent um for us and then
of course there was a couple of requests
could you just put it back up because
they wanted to have that
very good question so the best mandate
we have seen in the united states by the
way in the united states that has
done the amount of
declining of mobility as closure of
educational facilities
when schools closed and all states did
educational facility closure
first almost you know in all state about
40 to
50 percent decline in mobility
and again this is because schools are
associated with other activity besides
kids going to school
the reverse is true so now we have the
mandate in our model and lifting the
mandate because
right now if you look at it from the
different so in
lifting a mandate for school doesn't
mean mobility that declined when this
it was imposed will be the same the
reverse is not true because
even if kids go to school right now
families are not going to meet and have
a football game or a baseball game so we
still have a mandate and also in our
modeling we assume that
before any mandates mobility went down
by 10
15 depending on the state so we're
assuming
unless all mandates are lifted these
people who stayed at home early on
because they can't do or
because they have other conditions that
they are afraid to get out they're not
going to come out of their houses
until all mandates are lifted again
so there is a combination of the
mobility which is a better indicator in
our models right now and the
mandate itself has somehow an effect on
people behavior very good question
thank you so much now this next question
is about the mask mandate
in regards to the universal mask mandate
what are your thoughts on masks that do
not
filter particles as the nine
uh the n95 mask does are those masks
still effective no very good question so
we have a publication on this and we
have a lot of details on mask on our web
we have done a meta analysis for horse
studies that have been published on the
masks
and because over 19 is showing you we
didn't have many studies at that time
there were only two studies about mass
effect on covert 19 but we had
other respiratory diseases and we looked
at different types of
masks so uh of course the
impact of mass in reduction of uh
transmission varied from 40 to 60
percent 60 percent is and
the n95 time the 40
was the lowest we have seen which is a
cloth mask made at home for example
and in that 40 percent to tell you how
conservative we are in this estimate and
we may
be well underestimating the effect of
mass
we took the confidence interval of that
40 percent the lowest study
the least effective mass 40
and we took the lowest confidence
interval of that 40 which was 34
so we're assuming in our models the
effect of
mask if you wear a mask you reduce
transmission by 34
where in reality we know it could be
much higher
but any mask will work if warren
properly
and a closed mask and then of course
there are different type of masks some
of them are way better than the others
but a glass mask made at home when
you wear it properly red use
transmission by 34
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question dr macbeth
since the united states federal
government clearly has not enforced
any federal mandates how does this
affect the model
and projections or estimates in your
thought in your opinion
we we do it state by state so in our
case it's
the state itself right now we're moving
into doing this
by county when we even look at the
county like for example
some states florida miami had a mandate
for mass where the state didn't so we
want to factor that
in as well but since we don't have a
national
mandate that does not impact our
modeling because we're doing it at the
state level and we know what the states
are doing in terms of mandates
but i cannot let the question go without
commenting here and
thank you for whoever asked the question
i strongly
feel that the united states need a
national mandate
uh on mass because now we're confusing
the public you know we're
i have a cousin in arizona i have i mean
first cousin in
florida i mean it's confusing when you
and your family members or your parents
live in a different place with different
mandate in the same country so
having a national plan will help a lot
and will send the right message
will reduce confusion and of course the
united states needs a national plan not
a state plan to address this
pandemic
thank you so much and our last speaker
also said the same
exact thing dr magbad thank you so much
for your presentation today
and for your important research would
you like to provide any closing remarks
before we go today
oh thank you for the opportunity yes i
would love to tell everybody to be
safe wear a mask stay away from each
other
you know i'm in the business of
predictability i do these models to
predict what will happen
every time i release a model i wish and
i pray that i'm wrong
and people will prove me i am wrong by
winning a mask staying away from each
other washing their hands disinfected
disinfecting commonly used places
this pandemic is a disaster on all of us
it will have a long-term impact it's on
all of us we're so interconnected to
work together
to make sure we can control it it's our
behaviors
and we can do it if we all do our part
thank you for
listening and if you have any questions
i
put my email towards the end i'm happy
to take
questions later on as well thank you
everybody be
safe and thank you again dr my dad for
your time
and for your presentation before we go i
want to also thank our audience for
joining us for today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed
on demand for six months all the way up
to march
2021 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
this live event until next time take
care
be safe and stay healthy bye-bye
bye